i i seem to recall there was something
where where you were telling uh justin
bieber like to be careful
like with that
you know like like you could lose it all
and you were kind of trying to be a
mentor and then he got like kind of
nasty with you yeah you know justin
bieber and i we have a very peculiar
relationship like he hit me up on
instagram
and he was like
oh you know come over and hang out to my
house and i was like actually no you can
come over from mine
i got four wheelers and so i'm not
trying to just sit around look at
artwork
you know come over to my house i got
four wheelers atx's and bikes and we can
go ride around and actually you know
have some fun you know and then
when was that that was you know a year
ago
so and then there was an incident when
he was being a little [ __ ] i told
him on twitter i said if i see him i'll
punch you in your face
so how long ago was that uh like maybe
like
six seven years ago i don't know
something like that like he was doing
you guys are cool now
no we're not cool we're not no i invited
you over
again i'm i'm i'm his competitor man
like yeah like but a year ago he asked
you to come over yeah and i said no
and so when's the last time you talked
to him since then
i i don't really have anything to say to
justin bieber yeah i know like you know
uh he scooter braun
um you know it was it was very
interesting because when i released my
love album i did a billboard article
and then the next day
after i hadn't bitten out
with music for like 10 years
aaron rosenberg justin bieber's
entertainment attorney was asked a
question of course he approves all the
questions you know how it goes
how did you get justin bieber to not
turn out like aaron carter
wow and that was a question that was
asked to justin bieber's entertainment
attorney and i was livid because i had
just done a great article with them the
day before about mine coming back as
basically like a new artist that's
producing his music and not being
puppeted and doing it himself and
that that really hurt that really hurt
to see that and
to see like the boycotting because
there's this underlining smear campaign
cancel culture troll
boycott thing that we're all going
through everybody that's in this
industry i'm sure you're going through
it too
if i'm wrong i'm wrong you know tell me
go [ __ ] myself well getting boycotted
smear campaigns cancer cultures trolls
people making up lies doxing you um you
know
now that i've now that i've started to
really just get my life together it's
like
i feel like people are trying to
bring me back down to where i was before
and
i'm not that person anymore you know i'm
engaged i'm about to have a baby on the
way you know it's time to be a dad and
it's literally like a matter of a couple
days huh what yeah yeah yeah yeah
literally yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah
dude
[Music]
yeah dude